[Musique]
le bas saint laurent la région est
réputée dans le monde pour ses couchers
de soleil
ses paysages accueille la population la
plus vieillissante au québec à la mrc
des basques 33 % des citoyens ont plus
de 65 ans à rimouski un aîné doit
attendre jusqu'à deux ans pour avoir
accès à un logement subventionné
[Musique]
on les voit arriver quand un homme mais
on voit qu'ils des pires l'exemple et
qui ont besoin de plus de soins karine
l'évêque travail depuis cinq ans dans
cette résidence à but non lucratif où la
moitié des appartements sont
subventionnés et babel bonjour un site
d'hébergement abordable encore trop
rares et milliers et raymonde les vagues
vivent ici depuis trois ans comme les
autres résidents ils prennent le dîner
et le souper à la salle à manger
ces repas sont inclus dans le prix du
loyer de 1500 $ par mois
oui c'est parce qu'à l'intérieur la
résidence n'offrent pas de soins c'est
une infirmière du clsc qui vient soigner
monsieur les vagues en plus d'une
maladie pulmonaire chronique
monsieur lévesque est affaibli par une
prothèse à la hanche et depuis deux ans
il a une sonde mais le moral t-il coup
je vais vite et avec un acte le monde
le couple est marié depuis 68 une vie de
osez 2 bat incluant deux séparations qui
buvait puis devient agressif je faisais
mal aimés droite pour ce à travers la
vitrine aux brochets jamais vraiment la
vitrine louis jamais de vivre
bonjour pleyel aujourd'hui ils ne
peuvent s'imaginer vivre séparément
madame lévesque qui est en forme faut
tout faire pour garder son mari malade à
la maison on serait pas ici si on ne
sait si je le pouvais mais bon on est
joueur l'a jamais dit non même l'ol lui
est libyenne mais c'est surtout madame
l'éveil qui est de garde jour et nuit et
les nuits sont parfois très longue
j'ai eu ma peur je veux mourir je ne
buvais justin est fatigué
est ce que vous sentez que le seul essai
capable de répondre à tous ces besoins
la non aidées prochain date qui n'a pas
excédé par le ciel s est malheureusement
qui s'épuise qui suit est un mot qui
trouveront peut-être catastrophe parce
que au manque de personnel partout
l'ancien bloquiste que l'on retrouve
chez elle à saint fabien sur mer est
encore très engagé dans la communauté
un siège notamment à l'office
d'habitation de rimouski
la majorité des gens qui attendent un
logement abordable sont des aînés ça
devient extrêmement important qu'on
s'occupe du logement social
et qu'on arrête de dire que la
population vieillit ça fait longtemps
qu'ils vieillissent et pas une surprise
depuis monsieur chrétien gouvernement
fédéral a investi 1,7 dans l'ue
la femme de 82 ans suit encore de près
la politique
elle juge que les aînés sont les grands
oubliés de cette campagne électorale les
engagements ne sont pas à la hauteur des
besoins
on va augmenter le crédit en raison
d'âge par mille dollars 25% nom qui
payent pas d'impôts le parce qu'ils sont
pas assez riches pour en payer caisse
quand même qu'on leur promet très des
crédits d'impôts ça fait rien pour
résoudre b 1 1 c'est l'heure du bingo à
la résidence des aînés qui parle peu de
politique
même en ce lendemain de débats il juge
aussi avoir été oublié par les
politiciens
cette année on les a pas vu aucun aucun
aucun est revenu sur présenté hier aux
aînés je trouve ça un peu déplorable qui
a eu beau proche des vnx à savez-vous
pour qui vous allez voter raconte pas
votre dos on susurre solide mois était
facile de me choque pas je trouve ta en
51 milliards perdus comme au tai chi qui
connaît pas la réalité
de quoi vous avez besoin un peu plus de
déranger de stern au poste parce qu'on
est toujours j'ai bouclé les deux ailes
d'avoir des bateaux convenable pour nous
au talent à la situation pour nous et la
santé des milliers fort sera
éventuellement le couple a déménagé
c'est l'anniversaire de 6 milliards et
veillent donc mon anniversaire mais les
vagues mais comme ils n'ont pas les
moyens de payer une résidence qui offre
des soins
la seule option et le centre
d'hébergement de soins de longue durée
le redouté ch et celle des la boîte fait
de me sens bien d'un trou métapolis os
10.6 même pas passable au je pense que
le chien reste pas là telle ou telle
phrase est là là je pense pas que je
sois ya'bad à l'aise
une fiche gg je suis rendu à ce stade là
pour aller l'eau unibail à damas
saviez-vous capables ils s'ennuient non
je ne peux pas je veux remonter un peu
partout au canada
il manque cruellement de logements
subventionnés dans des résidences qui
offre des soins qui permettrait à des
couples aux moyens modestes de finir
leurs jours ensemble
[Musique]